In the U.S. and on the Internet
there has been a lot of talk about this question.
Why can't we open windows on a plane
and most of the discussion I've seen on this topic
has been completely unproductive.
People seem to be ignoring the fact that
this is an excellent question.
So, let's figure it out, why can't
we open windows on a plane.
Well the fundamental principle that works here
is the same principle that allows me to
drink water out of a straw.
It's the same phenomenon that causes your ears
to hurt, if you go too deep underwater too quickly
and what is this concept, it's this concept
called pressure. And we're specifically going to
talk about today is air pressure. So before we
get right into air pressure let's talk about air.